there are fuzzy political disagreements
in politics and then there are sort of
undeniable realities so as an example in
politics you can sometimes see
politicians play games with a defense
spending for example you'll have one
party saying we are raising defense
spending and the other party says we are
lowering defense spending or Democrats
want a lower defense spending and then
it becomes a disagreement over well is
defense spending going up in the
aggregate versus is the rate at which it
is going up decreasing if that sounds
confusing to you it's but because it's
exactly an example of the types of games
that are often played with politics in
the United States but sometimes we see
politicians just straight-up lie and
that gets us today to the case of the
us-mexico border
Donald Trump continues to hold rallies
where he insists that there is this
imminent crisis at the us-mexico border
he continues to threaten to declare a
national emergency if he doesn't get
money for his us-mexico border wall and
it is so undeniably clear that there
simply is no crisis at the border that a
second state governor is now sending
home the National Guard troops that
Donald Trump deployed to the border
there are four key border states with
the Mexico border California Arizona New
Mexico and Texas last week I told you
that New Mexico Governor Michelle
Grisham pulled almost all of the
National Guard troops in her state from
the border and yesterday California
Governor Gavin Newsom has signed an
order withdrawing almost all of the
troops stationed at the southern border
in the state of California why well as
he said yesterday Gavin Newsom saying
the border quote emergency is a
manufactured crisis there's no data to
defend there being a crisis at the
us-mexico border undocumented
immigration exists nobody would deny
that but governors are administrators if
they are thinking about a lot of these
things yes from a political perspective
but also from a much more logistical and
sort of sober
mathematical perspective and they are
seeing that there is no need for
National Guard troops at the border
number one more people are leaving than
coming in number two crossings
undocumented crossings illegal crossings
at the us-mexico border have been on a
decade-long decline number three
undocumented immigrants are less likely
to commit crime than american-born
citizens which makes sense because they
know if they get caught they face
deportation the border city of El Paso
Texas has one of the lowest crime rates
in the country for cities of its size
and it's been that way since before any
border fencing was installed there so
what we are seeing here is that it is
becoming undeniable that the border
crisis doesn't exist and the real crisis
is the President and what's going on at
the White House and the weaponization of
ignorance that's a term I've been using
now for six months or so weaponized
ignorant and the fact that 60 million
trump voters might reelect this guy if
we don't get it together between now in
the election that's the crisis and I
congratulate the governors of New Mexico
and California for simply saying what is
obviously true there isn't a crisis
we don't need National Guard troops at
the border and by the way as a sort of
caveat a cherry on top not that it even
matters at this point it's not clear
that it's legal to send National Guard
troops to the border because that is in
a sense a domestic law enforcement
action and the military is not supposed
to be used in that way will the
supporters of the wall the wall builders
ever get to a point where they can
number one admit that Donald Trump has
been defeated on the issue of the border
wall and number two recognized the
undeniable reality that there is no
crisis my prediction is no and we have
an interview today actually which we'll
delve into at a cognitive neuroscience
level why will they never concede that
let me know what you think I'm on
twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman
one of today's sponsors is privacy
dot-com / Pakman this is a free service
that I've actually been using myself for
a while now and I love it
you just take a few seconds to link your
debit card or bank account to privacy
coms mobile app or browser extension for
Firefox and Chrome and what that does is
allow you to instantly create virtual
credit cards that are linked to your
bank account so that you're not actually
putting your real debit card number on
the Internet and you use these virtual
credit card numbers to buy things online
and with one click of a button you have
the ability to create multiple virtual
cards delete cards freeze and unfreeze
cards you can put a limit on a card so a
company won't be able to charge you more
than you actually want them to and it
protects you from being hacked it
protects you from companies being hacked
which we've been talking about for a
while on the program and it's perfect
for signing up for free trial somewhere
if you don't want your real credit card
number to be exposed and on file and
their app and browser extension let you
autofill the virtual credit card number
into the credit card field when you're
buying things online there are a ton of
different advantages to shopping and
paying bills with a system like this
everything is totally secure and
encrypted and in some situations you can
earn 5% cash back on your purchases it's
all completely free all you have to do
is click the link under this video to
get started and for a limited time
everybody in our audience who signs up
gets $5.00 towards your first purchase
when you sign up using that link below